this is my memory palace by putting
images inside the space I can memorise
huge quantities of information ten decks
of shuffled playing cards lists of
hundreds of random words entire poems
and the first hundred digits of pi I'm
going to show you how the memory palace
works so that you can memorise the first
hundred digits of pi so you can't just
memorize a hundred digits of a random
number most of us are just not going to
be able to do that the technique that I
use is called the major system so using
this code you can convert any number
into a word and then into an image that
you can visualize in your memory palace
41 4 is an r1 is a TRD could be RT R at
five to seven to look no no Lincoln
eight to zero two seven one zero zero
one four to seven eight two three nine
four zero seven two three to zero three
one to seven so we're gonna do with PI
is break this number up into three-digit
chunks and come up with a unique image
for each chunk one for one the road of
could be a druid five nine to LA but no
olivian like somebody from Libya maybe
it's moammar qaddafi six five three sure
look ma could be somebody shouting
Shalom so basically these 33 images are
the first hundred digits of pi now let's
go to my memory palace so now I picture
myself standing outside the memory
palace and there's the druid chillin on
the front lawn then I walk through the
door into the house into a living room
and there's Qaddafi sitting on the
yellow sofa right next to him a little
shouting Shalom we turned the
corner of the coffee table and there is
a wolf peeing on the nice laminate floor
right above him there is a picture going
kaboom and then just beneath that is a
nymph two three eight sitting
cross-legged on the floor
we're passing from the living room into
the bedroom and right there on the left
for six - a Russian doll next to the
Russian doll piping-hot falafel filled
with schwarmann on the bed MF M male
female male pornographic scenes and
hanging from the wall big bony kneecap
and I walk into the bathroom it's a
beautiful bathroom there's Wilson the
volleyball from castaway he's sitting on
the toilet inside the shower is gonna be
Michelle Pfeiffer and on a coffee table
little bathroom reading top a book and
then 169 on the wall Toshiba logo next
to that 399 male pattern baldness I walk
into the kitchen and there's Michael
Jackson moonwalking across the laminate
floor next to him a humming diesel motor
and then on the wall of these phones
that are buzzing and in front of them a
baker I can smell the bread baking in
the oven and in front of him is a
barrier I'm gonna lift up that barrier
and walk into the hallway
it's moammar qaddafi again and behind
him a Lucha Libre mask a pair of red
high-heeled leather dominatrix boots a
horse shoe a no-fishing sign an unsafe
sign a big bottle of cheap pop of vodka
and there I see an ocean view and then I
walk outside of the house into the
backyard it's summer and behind that
funnel and helen mirren
and then 1 1 7 fish riding a bicycle I
don't know because that's idiotic
0 6 7 Pat Sajak the host from wheel of
fortune and that's my memory cows that's
how I visualize the first hundred digits
of pi ok so now let's see if I can
actually do this 3.14159265 three five
eight nine seven nine three two three
eight four six two six four three three
eight three two seven nine five zero two
eight eight four one nine seven one six
nine three nine nine three seven five
one zero five eight two zero nine
seven four nine four four five nine two
three zero seven eight one six four zero
six two eight six two zero eight nine
nine eight six two eight zero three four
eight two five three four two one one
seven zero six seven did it okay all
right sweet that should have taken me
about half as much time as it did I used
to be a veritable lou ferrigno of memory
strength and now I'm just like a fat old
mnemonic schlub I'm embarrassed by that
performance but at least I didn't make
any mistakes